ladies and gentlemen your Artemis 2 crew
with a pep rally style event at NASA's
Johnson Space Center in Houston the four
astronauts took a bow on stage Mission
Commander Reed Wiseman is a former test
pilot with 14 years at NASA
awesome to be here with you guys Mission
specialist Christina Koch will be the
engineer on board am I excited
absolutely
physicist Jeremy Hansen is a Canadian
space agency astronaut a Canadian is
going to the Moon with our International
partnership and it is glorious
and former U.S Navy Airman Victor Glover
will be the spacecraft's pilot because
Artemis 2 is more than a mission to the
Moon and back it's more than a mission
that has to happen before we send people
to the surface of the Moon
it is the next step on the journey that
gets Humanity to Mars
the Artemis program named after the
ancient Greek goddess of the moon sent
its first uncrewed spacecraft into lunar
orbit last year Atop The Powerful Orion
rocket that successful flight paved the
way for next year's human crude Mission
if all goes well Artemis 2 will put
humans near Earth's Cosmic companion for
the first time since Apollo 17 in 1972.
on the four-day Mission the crew will
travel more than 40 million kilometers
orbiting the moon and testing systems
and Equipment it's all in preparation
for the next mission which is planned to
touch down on the lunar surface sometime
in 2025.
Rob Reynolds Al Jazeera